翻訳: Naoko Hirami
校正: Hiroko Kawano
おばあちゃんが骨折をしてしまいました
手術はうまくいきました
でも歩けるようになるためには
リハビリが必要です
リハビリは筋力回復のために
膝を屈伸する運動 —
この単調な運動を
毎日繰り返さないといけません
おばあちゃんはそれが退屈なので
なかなか続けることができません
じゃぁ どうすればいいでしょうか？
これはですね
私が学長を務めております —
神戸情報大学院大学の学生が
実際に直面した課題です
彼は自分に何ができるか考えました
ICT技術を学んでいるので
それを使って何かできないかを
考えたんですね
それで彼がいろいろ試行錯誤して
作ったものが これです
彼がやったことは
おばあちゃんの足の動きを
モーションセンサーっていうもので
キネクト これで感知して
パソコンに情報を取り込んで
Googleマップを使って
おばあちゃんが足を動かすと
バーチャル旅行ができる
こういう仕組みを作ってくれました
それによって おばあちゃんは
つまならなかったリハビリが面白くなって
がんばって毎日継続するようになって
元気になった
こういったことが起こりました
神戸情報大学院大学っていうのは
ICT技術を学ぶ大学院です
ICT技術は皆さんが毎日使う
スマホのアプリもこれもICT技術があれば
企業や政府が 企業に発注して
大規模なシステム これもICT技術
いずれにせよ
すごく使われているシステムと
あまり使われないシステムがあります
私は自分の学生に社会で活躍してほしいので
やっぱり役立つようなシステムを
作ってほしいなと思いました
そこで彼らに呼びかけたのは
「なんか人に喜んでもらえるような
仕組みを作ろうよ」
ということを呼びかけました
学生は身近に存在する課題をみつけて
それに対する解決策 仕組みを考えます
それを技術を使って
どうやって実現するかという事を考えて
実際に現場で作ってやってみて
使ってもらって
どうですか？これで役に立ちましたか？
と確認する検証 これをやります
この一連のプロセスを
私は「探究実践」と名付けて
カリキュラムに組み込んで
学生に実践してもらいました
もう少し例を挙げますと
例えば皆さんは忘れ物とか
落とし物されますか？
私は自分で忘れ物大魔神って
呼んでるんですけども
眼鏡とか携帯とかカバンとか上着とか
あらゆる物をあらゆる所に
置いてきてしまいます
毎日なにかを探し回って
困っているんですけど
そうすると学生がですね
忘れ物 落とし物を防止する —
あるいは してしまっても
見つけるような仕組みを作りたい
タグを使ってやるんだって考えてくれました
「それいいなぁ！どんどんやってよ！」
そんな感じですね
それからタイが大好きな学生は
タイ語の入力システムっていうのを
作ってくれました
あるいは家庭の節電が
重要になっているということで
節電を支援する仕組みを作ろう —
そういった学生もいます
どうしてこんなことが
可能になっているかっていうと
今オープンソーステクノロジーというのが
どんどん普及しています
過去に誰かが作ったプログラムとか
あるいはハードウェアとか
そういったものが
自分で全部作ると 大変ですけども
そういった過去の「知」っていうものが
タダ あるいは非常に安価に手に入ります
だから学生でもゼロから作るんじゃなくて
いろんなものを組み合わせて作ることができる
ちなみに先ほど言った
リハビリシステムを作った学生は
文科系の大学の出身なんですね
別にプログラムのエキスパート
だったわけでもなんでもありません
でも先人の知恵を組み合わせれば
こんなものができてしまう
面白い時代になったと思います
そうやって探究実践っていうのを
ずっと日本でやってきたわけですけれども
これが３年前から突然
海外に急速に展開することになったんです
きっかけは JICAさんとの出会いで
JICAの方から教えて頂いたんですけれども
今アフリカ中心に途上国で
ICTを使った課題解決っていうのが
非常にホットなトピックになっているんですよ
と教えて頂きました
そういったことを聞いて
私もアフリカに行ってみることにしました
けっこうICTに力を入れている
ルワンダっていう国に行ってきました
ルワンダって皆さん
どういうイメージがありますか？
ちょっと怖いイメージもないですか？
私もなくはなかったんですけど
行ってみて まず安心したのは
私 例によってバッグを３回もレストランに
忘れてきてしまったんですけど
３回とも戻ってきたんですね
あぁこの国は安全だな 素晴らしいな
まずそう感じました
都会はけっこう発展しています
ちょっと足を伸ばして農村に行くと
電気も水もありません
水は例によってカメに乗せて
頭の上に乗せて運んでいます
そんな農村がいっぱいある
ところが けっこうみんな
携帯を持っているんですよ
それからスマホも
どんどん安くなっているので
スマホの普及も
時間の問題と言われています
電気もないのに携帯があるのか
と思われるかもしれません あるんですね
じゃぁ充電どうやってやるんだ？
充電屋さんがあるんですよちゃんと
そこに持って行ったら充電してくれる
電気も水もないけど携帯はある
こういった中で何ができるかってことを
彼らは一生懸命考えています
この写真なんだと思いますか？
溝が掘ってありますよね
これはルワンダが ICT立国っていうことで
光ファイバーケーブルを国中に
巡らせようということで
農民がみんなで鍬で穴掘って
光ファイバーを埋めたんです
全土何百キロ張り巡らす
その絵を見てすごいな びっくりした
それからこれはITバスです
バスの中に発電機とサーバーと
20台のパソコンがあります
これが農村に行って農村の若者 —
電気もない農村の若者に
パソコンの使い方を教えてるITバス
これ見て本当にみんな一生懸命
パソコンやってるんですね
すごく感銘しました
そういった中で そうは言っても
ルワンダのような途上国は
まだまだ課題がいっぱいあります
農業あるいは教育 医療
そういった基本的なものが
まだまだ非効率だったり
質のいいものが受けられなかったり
様々な問題がある
それをITを使って例えば
遠隔で教育とか医療をやっていこう
いろんなアイデアがあります
でもそれが実現するのは
まだそう簡単ではありません
なぜかって言うと そういったことを考えて
実行できる人がまだまだ少ない
まだまだ知識とか技術も少ないですし
技術を仮に持っていても実現するだけの
経験とかノウハウがまだまだない
そういったことがあってJICAさん主催で
私の神戸情報大学院大学に
30人のアフリカ人が８か国からやってきた
これが３年前です
私も生まれて初めて英語で授業するし
ましてやアフリカ人を教えるなんて
初めてなんで
どうなることかドキドキしていました
まず感じたことは
彼らはすごくレスポンスがいいんですね
役立つと思ったらグッときて
グッと吸収します
一方でつまんないなと思ったら
コテンと寝てしまいます
分かりやすすぎるなぁって
それから
日本のいろんな所に連れて行きました
学校とか病院とか農村とかで
ITがうまく使われているような事例を
いろいろ見てもらいました
彼らはすごく刺激を受けていて
「面白い 」「日本てすごい国ですね」
「こんないろんな工夫がされてて
すごいですね」って感動してました
逆に僕もそんな感動されて
嬉しいなっていう感じだったんですけども
やっぱり我々はいろんな工夫をしてきたんだな
という事を改めて感じました
そうやっていろいろ吸収してもらって
６週間のプログラムが終わる頃には
彼らも自分たちの国の農業とか
医療とかの課題に対して
ITを使ったアイデアをいろいろ持って
提案を作って帰ってくれました
「探究実践おもしろい 使えるな
もっと自分の国に広めたい」とか
「また神戸に来て学びたい」とか
いろいろ言ってくれて
すごく私も嬉しかったんですね
これはけっこういいなっていうことで
じゃぁもっと広げていこうっていうことで
２年間の修士課程 —
我々は「ICTイノベータマスタープログラム」
と言ってるんですけども —
２年間の探究実践と技術を学ぶ
プログラムを作りました
幸い JICAさん 文科省の様々な
奨学金プログラムに採択されて
たくさんの留学生が
やってくることになりました
これは私の授業の風景なんですけども
アフリカだけじゃなくてアフガニスタンとか
バングラデシュとか
いろんな国から来てくれてみんな
国から選ばれて来た人なんで
やっぱり優秀な方が多い
やる気もすごいんで
喧々諤々議論してやってます
それで最近数えてみると
この３年間でなんと
30か国100人以上の人が
我々の探究実践を学んでくれたことになる
ということがわかって
おお けっこうきたなっていう感じです
ちょっとひとつ事例を紹介したいと思います
これは ルワンダからやってきた
20代半ばの学生なんですけども
彼は防災の担当の官庁で働いています
日本でも先日残念ながら
洪水で事故がありましたけども
彼も ルワンダでも洪水で
けっこう人が死んじゃうということで
彼は洪水で死ぬ人を減らしたいっていう
強い思いを持っています
まず彼がやった事は
日本とか先進国の事例を調べて
どんな防災システムがあるんだ
ということを調べました
そうするとやっぱり洗練されたシステムが
いろいろあります
ただそのままではルワンダでは
使えないということもわかりました
それはなぜかって言うと
先進国のシステムって
電気とか ネットワークとか
そういったインフラが
通じてることが当たり前 —
そういった状況の中で使われている
あるいは非常に洗練されたシステムなので
コストも高い 何億 何十億とする
これはこのままではインフラもない
お金も少ないルワンダではちょっと無理だな
ということで彼は自分で工夫をして安価で
かつ実用的なシステムを作ろうと考えました
彼は技術者ではないので
技術の詳しい日本人の学生とか
教員の助けを借りながら
自分で一生懸命作りました
やっぱりオープンソースを使って
このソーラーパネルとか
Arduinoって安いパソコンとか
センサーとか
そういったものを組み合わせて作った
いろいろ考えた中で作ったシステムの
ひとつがこれです
ある意味 原始的に
川の水が増量した時に
それをセンサーで測って検知して
そしたらサイレンが鳴るっていう
そういう仕組みを作ってくれました
これが神戸の六甲山の山の上で
実際に水が上がったらサイレンが鳴るのか
実験しているところなんですけども
サイレンの音がすごく大きいので
近所迷惑なので
なかなか実験する場所を見つけるのに
苦労したって彼は言ってましたけど
実験はうまくいったんですね
もちろんこれを実際に実現するためには
いろいろ課題はあると思います
だから彼はこれでこの研究で論文も書いて
複数の学会で発表してけっこう
注目されるような研究もやってくれました
そういったことでこの私の大学院で
けっこう国境を越えて
日本人あるいは外国人留学生 技術者
あるいは技術者でない人が一緒になって
わいわいガヤガヤ探究しています
けっこうおもしろい発展がしてきて
今ABEイニシアティブっていうプログラムが
あるんですけれども
５年間で1000人のアフリカ人を
日本の大学院に呼んで
２年間でマスターを取ってもらって帰って
それで日本企業とアフリカの懸け橋になって
もらおうと こういうプログラムがあります
そういった中で私の大学院
神戸情報大学院大学が
今受け入れ数で全国の中で２番
技術系では一番多いと
いうことになっています
そこで留学にきた学生と日本企業
あるいは
JICAさんとかJETROさんの支援も得て
日本の企業が
その学生といろいろ協力して
アフリカに行って課題解決あるいは
BOPビジネスをやろう
そういったことを
どんどん発展してきています
まだまだ始まったばっかりですけども
本当にこの
ITを使った課題解決の探究実践が
面白いことになってるなって
感じています
ちょっと振り返ってみると
日本って
技術を使って社会を良くするってことが
けっこう得意ですよね
新幹線に代表されるように
技術 ハイテク 得意です
じゃぁ何が新しいのか考えてみると
ひとつはオープンソースとかによって
個人でも —
大きな企業でなくても個人でも
ベンチャー企業でも
けっこう面白い事が
トライできるようになった
自分でこんなことを作ってみたいって事を
主体的にトライできる
これはすごく面白いと思います
さらにそれが日本だけじゃなくて
遠く離れた途上国の人にも貢献できる
彼らの幸せっていうものに貢献できる
笑顔を作っていける
そういったこともできるようになった
という風に感じています
大学院のキャッチフレーズは
「Social Innovation by ICT & Yourself」です
自分が動くことによって
社会を変えることができる
そういう風に思います
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）